[Music]
summer is the season when classic and
vintage cars really get the shine and
Germany these older models are becoming
increasingly popular over the last nine
years the number of cars licensed as
historical vehicles has increased by
almost a quarter of a million today the
classic and vintage car club old-timer
club line EFT is holding a get-together
it's an event the whole family can enjoy
[Music]
one by one the cars set off and make
their way to the group picnic
everything from Rolls Royces to Mercedes
and BMWs some are very rare like this
Porsche 356 speedster it was the car
makers first series production vehicle
but here even cars that aren't
collectors items have their day in the
Sun plenty of these vehicles are worth a
second glance because all brands of cars
are welcome at the line Ave Club the
diversity is great these cars represent
a half a century of automotive history
[Music]
the old cars get a break while they wait
for the entire convoy to arrive in the
meantime the drivers and passengers
enjoy some food and refreshments mon
fiducial has arrived in his 1962 Rolls
Royce Silver Cloud he says they have
excursions like this twice a year it's a
tradition but Bushell feels the nicest
thing about them is the community as you
can see behind him folks sit together
chat and enjoy a potluck lunch and talk
about cars and everything under the Sun
gives them a boost if they've had a hard
week and work in on a stressful business
trip or having it rough as a retiree
this 50 year old Mercedes 250 SL is also
taking part in the excursion its owner
dirk organ really enjoys the club's
picnics
he feels they're important because they
promote the sense of community within
the club though they all know one
another these are experiences that stay
with you for a long time others collect
watches their common obsession is old
cars
whether they're passionate collectors
hobby mechanics or just want to drive
one of the cars from their childhood the
passion for old cars unites all kinds of
people and they enjoy different aspects
of these get-togethers this man says
it's great to spend the day with other
club members and take the family along
as they're not always at the clubs
evening meetings others take full
advantage of the chance to talk shop
this car buff says what's most important
to him is being around like-minded
individuals here he can pursue his hobby
without reservation and without worrying
about talking everyone's ear on March
10th Anita says his family's not always
so understanding when he talks about
cars non-stop but his buddies at the
club can't get enough so it's great to
chat with them Dagmar Peretz was happy
enough to have someone else drive her to
todays picnic she enjoys the camaraderie
especially talking to the wives and
girlfriends of the club's predominantly
male members she says it's nice to eat
and chat with them and talk about things
other than cars
but the rhein AFT antique car club
doesn't just organize these
get-togethers for the owners benefit it
also does it for the cars they need
regular workouts fiducial says the older
the car the more often things go wrong
with it these cars need to be driven but
then of course things can't happen
but if you don't use them even more can
go wrong cars go kaput just from
standing around at a club you meet
others with similar problems who know
how to solve them here you can find help
for the club's members owning a classic
or vintage model is about more than just
having a nice old car to call your own
it's about being part of a community of
like-minded people people who are all
crazy about old cars
[Music]